The new Game of Thrones Season 8 teaser shows
the crypts of Winterfell – where thousands
of years of dead Starks are entombed .
Jon Snow carries a torch through the darkness,
which fits the imagery of Azor Ahai – a
hero prophesied to defeat the darkness with
a sword called Lightbringer .
Jon passes the tomb of Lyanna Stark. Jon doesn’t
know it, but Lyanna is his mother. She fell
in love with Rhaegar Targaryen, but she died
giving birth to Jon. Lyanna’s brother Ned
promised to “protect” Jon, by saying that
Jon is his child .
A feather falls from Lyanna’s statue. It
was put there in Season 1 by King Robert,
who had loved Lyanna. In Season 5, Sansa finds
this feather, and talks about how Rhaegar
supposedly kidnapped and raped Lyanna – which
we now know isn’t true . Maybe this feather
represents the truth of Lyanna and Rhaegar’s
love – and of Jon’s real heritage.
Sansa sees the tomb of her mother Catelyn.
In the books, Cat is resurrected as a zombie
called Stoneheart, so it’s funny to see
Cat as a statue made of stone. We hear a line
from Season 3 – when Catelyn said she’d
once made a “promise” to love Jon. But
Catelyn found she couldn’t love Jon – cause
she thought he was Ned’s bastard. Cat felt
that this broken promise caused all the “horror”
that comes to House Stark . So this is a reminder
of how the Stark family has suffered – and
of the pain caused by the secret of Jon’s
birth.
Jon sees the tomb of Ned Stark. We hear a
line from Season 1 – where Ned says that
Jon may be a bastard, but he’s still Ned’s
“blood” – which is true in that Ned
is Jon’s uncle. Ned promises that next time
he sees Jon, they’ll talk about his mother
. So these three voiceover lines all refer
to promises made about Jon – Ned’s promise
to protect Jon, Cat’s promise to love Jon,
and Ned’s promise to talk about Jon’s
mum. Of course, tragically, Ned dies, and
Jon Snow still knows nothing. So when will
Jon find out about his parents?
There are hints in the books that Jon will
learn the truth in the crypts. Jon has dreams
of the crypts where the statues say “You
are no Stark” . And there are rumours of
a dragon in the crypts – which might be
a metaphor for Jon finding his Targaryen dragon
identity there . In the show, Jon might just
learn the truth from Sam or Bran. [] But either
way, how will Jon react to learning that he’s
not Ned’s bastard? That his real name is
Aegon , that he’s heir to the Throne ? Will
he start acting like a Targaryen? Riding dragons,
burning enemies, marrying aunts? Or will Jon
stay true to his Stark identity? [] Rhaegar
is Jon’s father, but Ned is the man who
raised him. Jon upholds Ned’s legacy and
values – like Ned says, Jon is a Stark . So
just like Theon can be a Greyjoy and a Stark
. Jon can be a Stark and a Targaryen.
Jon, Sansa and Arya see statues of themselves
– representing their deaths. A cold fogs
rolls in, representing the white walkers and
their army of the dead. The fallen feather
freezes, which might mean the death of life
on Westeros. So like Lyanna and Cat and Ned
before them, will Jon Sansa and Arya die this
season? They’re all stronger than they’ve
ever been. Jon a heroic king, Sansa a political
player, Arya a Faceless assassin. But “all
men must die” , and this is the end of Game
of Thrones.
By the way, it is weird that Bran isn’t
in this trailer – he’s the only living
Stark not included. Maybe it’s because Bran
has lost his identity by becoming the three-eyed
raven – will Bran find himself again, or
become a tree-man like the last raven?
So this trailer is about Stark identity, Jon’s
parentage, and the deathly threat of the white
walkers. But we can go deeper into the crypts.
They are vast and dark and ancient – there
are lots of theories on what secrets lie within.
In the books, the crypt statues are often
described as “watching” and “listening”
. Sometimes they “seem to stir” , “as
if the dead were rising” . Fans speculate
that the dead Starks might rise to fight for
Winterfell, like the dead in the Lord of the
Rings. Or maybe they’ll be fight for the
white walkers. Cause fans speculate that the
Starks are descended from the white walkers
and the Night’s King . Maybe the Night’s
Queen is imprisoned deep in the crypts, and
the white walkers are coming to rescue her.
Or maybe the Great Other, the god of the white
walkers , is down there, and Winterfell was
built to contain him. Rhaegar’s harp could
be down there, or the Horn of Winter, or Hot
Pie’s secret herbs and spices. There’re
lots of possibilities, but this stuff is more
in the books than the show – so we’ll
cover the crypts in another video.
Comment below what you wanna know about the
crypts, Starks and Winterfell – and please
like and subscribe. Artwork is by Oriana Wiesner,
Rae Lavergne, and Ertac Altinoz – who low-key
predicted this trailer. Thanks to the Patrons
who support Alt Shift X, including Peter Alex,
Trisha Hopkins, Mykhailo Granik, Sally Sheehy,
Ross M G, Joshua Hillard, Danielle Larson,
Infinite and Rookwood. Cheers.